foreign
Giovanni is going to start off this hour
in New York City hi Giovanni how are you
how are you doing Dave I'm great
good how can we help
so my question is uh pretty brief um I
work at a cell phone retail company and
I'm looking to increase my income on
studying to the software engineer I
don't know if you guys were aware of the
Google keynote that came out not too
long ago regarding their new Ai and they
stated that their new AI knows over 200
plus different coding languages so in
your opinion should I still should it
still be worth it for me to study
software engineering or should I be
doing something else yes and the reason
is is even though that is true it is
their AI that can do that because of the
software Engineers they employ so I've
interviewed two AI experts and if you
want to get into software engineering AI
is not going to eliminate your abilities
to work in fact AI can only do what a
human programs it to do is it
intelligent yes but the reason they call
it AI artificial intelligence is because
a human software engineer software
developers are creating the code that
give the AI the ability to do what it's
going to do so you're going to be in
more demand than ever because AI is
coming like a freight train it's here
it's going to continue to expand but you
will be as valuable as ever so I would
not let that headline in any way deter
you let me let me give you a parallel
lots and lots of Industries have been
disrupted by technology AI is a
technology and it is going it is a major
disrupter it's going to cause all kinds
of things to happen it's pretty pretty
uh wonderful in one sense and scary in
another because the level of piracy the
level of counterfeits that are going to
come out of this or just if it's if some
boundaries of some kind even if they are
put on it you've always got the Russian
mafia or whatever hackers are going to
do what they're going to do right so you
you know this thing is it's it's a
powerful for good or for evil weapon
that has been Unleashed and it is there
so that's the reality now on a much
simpler plane about the time I came out
of high school when the dinosaurs were
roaming the Earth uh computers were
starting to kind of come on the scene
and uh three of my buddies were studying
to be architects
and computers suddenly were able to do
drafting uh with What's called the cad
system that is still in use today
although a much more sophisticated
version than 30 or 40 years ago but uh
the cad you know computer automated
drafting uh it's a lot easier to draw a
house plan or draw a building plan today
a lot faster than it was in the old days
when you had to draw it by hand now your
computer program can do it but you still
need people with draftsman skills and
you still need Architects to tell the
cad what to do and Engineers to tell the
cad what to do and so that's the
situation that we're the exact same
thing we're talking about here it did
not do away with the need for
Professionals in the industry it made
them much more efficient that's right
and people sitting if you wanted to sit
at a draftsman's board with a ruler
and uh whatever the tools were and draw
all day long oh you're out of business
you're done because no one does that
anymore because they it's no one it's
it's impossible to keep up with how fast
a computer can do that much faster than
a human but
um but to be able to tell the computer
what to do requires the exact same set
of skills yeah I want to give our
audience that may resonate with this
question here from Giovanni two pieces
of news so that you can get over the
fear factor number one we are seeing
right now there's about a job and a half
available a technology job just in
general tech jobs uh for every person
that wants to get in it so the
opportunity is massive in Tech number
two most of you have seen headlines
throughout the last six months about
major companies like meta Facebook's
parent company Google Lane tens and tens
of thousands of Technology workers off
and people go oh no but here's the deal
now the data's come back Dave that those
workers are getting hired within a month
for other smaller companies in these big
tech companies this is what they do they
staff up you had you had companies like
Redfin their CEOs Google your Salesforce
admitting that they over hired to keep
Talent away from their competition and
so the minute that the recession word
gets uttered these public companies
ordered about their stock price and they
drop talent but here's the deal those
people are getting rehired quickly so
all that to say if you want to go into
software I can't think of a better field
to get into right now yeah it's um
and you know creatives and content
producers yes of any kind audio video
that's right blogging all of that is
going to be affected yes but enhanced
here's the thing you have to in order to
be a thought leader you have to have a
thought
isn't that true and and so you know the
AI cannot replace that and and so art
Artistry you know quality graphic
production
um has to be installed by someone who
has the eye that's correct even if it is
then reproduced and replicated in its
various forms by AI so it's still there
and you still got to look at it and go I
think I'm going to use human judgment
here and say that sucks yeah I mean you
can still have that as a possibility my
guys typed in the other day that just to
make fun of me oh no in the in the chat
thing yeah the chat thing you know Dave
Ramsey does a rant against AI
and it it formulated something oh it
wrote out a room yeah how mad I was at
Ai and it was pretty nasty when it was
um I mean not not nasty like vulgar okay
I was gonna say they didn't add some
color that you know
AI wouldn't have found me saying that
because that's right okay it has to find
something you've actually used to get
the tone right oh yeah and it picked it
up but it was uh pretty much like me
ranting against credit card debt or
student loan debt but just Ai and they
just oh that's an overlay in it that
sounds fun obviously I didn't do that
but um because I'm not anti-ai and I'm
not freaked out about it uh the only
thing I'm actually worried about is just
that the stinking stuff steals
everything that and honestly a person in
piracy the piracy I mean the number of
copyrights and trademarks and images and
brands that we have developed at Great
expense uh ill you know a a nefarious
use well here's another steal it well
here's what I'm concerned about people
doing deep fake stuff yeah where they
can put words in your mouth yeah and
literally create you saying something
you never said and I would just say as a
caution yeah please folks yeah that
we've joke about don't believe
everything you read or see on the
internet I think AI is going to make a
lot of crazy wacky stuff out there you
better consider your Source yeah that's
the kind of stuff like an effective
presidential election yes sir you know
they come out has yeah Biden's saying
something that made sense or something
oh
that's an interesting use of it maybe
they should try that
he strung a sentence together what
happened this is the Ramsay show